Nope.
Thanks for you're welcome.
And good afternoon.
And uh,
I'm happy to come over here.
I said I joined NASA Ames in 1987 so I have memory of when a Google had an SBAR
contract,
you know,
single digits,
but uh,
and I live near way most.
So I get to see the parade of,
uh,
vehicles passing by my front yard every evening around 10 o'clock headed back
into the mothership I guess.
So have a watched with some interest and I'm honored to have been asked to come
out and talk a little bit about some of what I'm doing on the other side of
Stevens Creek along with my colleagues and peers over there.
So the picture behind me,
you could argue a relates to possibly,
maybe not self driving vehicles,
but it is an autonomous rover and then NASA,
his case,
we tend to use those for moving our instruments and means of,
uh,
gathering samples and data to far away places.
Going back to,
uh,
and most recent Mars history,
we've had a curiosity and the Mer rovers back in the two thousands and
pathfinder before that.
And,
um,
one of the follow ons to curiosity or to the Mars science laboratory as it was
then called,
it was something called the Mars astrobiology field laboratory or AFL having
nothing to do with football leagues.
But uh,
in about the 2007 or 2006 timeframe,
there was going to be something based on the chassis and on the technology that
currently went into what was then going to be the 2009 Msl mission and a with a
two meter coring drill a means to handle that material and get it up from
underneath the surface and then crush pieces of it.
Subsample pick it apart.
And why do we want to do this?
Well,
one of the things is that we are,
people are interested in looking for biomarkers,
for signs of life in could life have existed in places other than on earth.
The astrobiology question
was,
oh,
we,
this was a proposed mission to figure out where their habitable zones or at
least on Mars and how those zones might have developed and what does that tell
us about earth as well as the evolution of Mars?
And to look for any specific biomarkers or uh,
evidence.
If we found anything.
There were concepts of this that had went down to the point of specing
specifying what it should include.
It had to have some means to get sample.
If you're going to look for organics or past cellular debris or anything else
that might be stuck that might give you evidence of it that was once habitable.
There needs to be some mains to get the sample in the first place.
So it had the,
I guess as I said,
a two meter drills,
sample transfer could sub sample course could deliver these things to
instruments.
So self driving and self handling and self drilling.
However,
if you're looking for life,
this complicates things.
The current curiosity rover is not sterilized to the levels that would be
necessary to send it into what we call a uh,
COSPAR special region.
A special region is a place where maybe just maybe life could exist under some
conditions.
If you happen to introduce the right microbe and you happened to warm it up and
put it in the radio.
Basically places where you could maybe terraform by accident if you weren't
careful.
So we don't want to do that,
especially not unintentionally,
you know,
can you talk to your favorite science fiction author otherwise about the
advisability of this?
But you know,
the,
we have agreements that we are going to try to protect other planetary
environments,
not just a spoiled them as it were.
Also,
if you're looking for signs of life,
you have to make sure you're not just,
uh,
you know,
looking at your own foot,
so to speak,
that you're not simply discovering the microbes that you,
or the biomarkers you brought with you.
So contamination avoidance,
you have to be very,
very,
very clean both to protect where you're going and to make sure that your results
have some validity.
And then how would you know if you,
you know,
if there was life there,
if you saw it now,
you might find weird life silicon bay store,
something we haven't even imagined yet.
So it's,
you know,
the,
it becomes,
how do you detect that something you don't know about,
but you can at least come up with instruments to detect earth-based life.
So all of these were concepts of this astrobiology field laboratory mission that
was supposed to follow and eventually became the 2020 rover,
which is not an astrobiology field mission.
And maybe in the 20 twenty's we will get an AFL mission.
And that leads us into our ads in some sense because you know,
after the AFL idea was shelved,
there's the desire to figure out how would you look for signs of life?
How would you take a mobile platform,
how would you sub sample,
how would you drill those?
Those issues didn't go away.
So it was sort of inspired by the astrobiology field lab rover concepts starting
about 2010 after AFL is canceled and we started putting together proposals and
working and tinkering with them.
And in 2014 we put together the proposal shown here with a rover,
a two meter automated drill from honeybee,
a sample transfer arm with a scoop on the end of it.
They could either scoop material like the Phoenix mission or could take powdered
cuttings or material from the drill and carry it over to instrument.
It could do double duty in a sense as well as instruments.
If you think back to those AFL calls for looking at habitability and as well as
for signs of life.
Well we had the a reef lie of the Phoenix's wet chemistry laboratory discovered
perchlorates on Mars and half of the exomars planned moma instrument.
Basically a laser disruption mass spec.
That way we don't have to incinerate our sample,
so using the laser to ping it in effect,
we can hopefully catch the right ions and we will detect things that we
otherwise would just incinerate if we have to do parallel paralysis.
And uh,
he did up the Spanish solid instruments.
Signs of life detector is an Amino Assay.
I sometimes joke to folks,
it's like certified [inaudible] 512 home pregnancy tests printed on a chip.
That's gross over oversimplification of course.
But it is an immunoassay.
You're looking for a specific molecules or specific compounds specific to
organisms or specific,
you know,
you can look,
pick your favorite amino acid,
you only get a grid of them.
So if you don't pick the right 256 so the right 512 and you get something else
instead,
you don't see it.
So that's the drawback.
On the other hand,
you can look for a lot of different things and it will fluoresce and it'll tell
you if you've got a positive hit.
Just like with many uh,
medical tests now.
And finally the wood there has been an instrument called the chemical laptop
electrophoresis based micro fluidic instrument developed at Berkeley about this
point 1214 years ago.
And the descendants of the chemical laptop and various places are being
developed into instruments both at JPL and Nasa Ames actually as we speak and
put into various mission proposals.
The microfluidic life analyzer is one of these,
it's coming from JPL in this case.
And,
uh,
it would be able to give us amino acids and their curiosity and we could have
some idea of the,
what we are looking at and if this was from a biogenic origin or not based on
what we could get from that.
So we put this together as a package proposed for increasing capabilities,
starting from basically just taking the pieces out to the Atacama to putting
things on the rover with the drill and the arm too.
Then in integrating instruments.
Then finally operating the whole thing remotely from the u s and sort of a
mission style operation.
So got picked in early 2015 and a with our partners at honeybee and in Spain and
I'm JPL and Goddard and so forth.
So off we went.
The basic concept is we will go to a earth analog site,
something that is,
has some aspects or some attributes that are similar if the we be,
the feel is similar in some respects to another planet.
We,
in this case,
we were looking for someplace with a very low bioburden this very dry,
very desiccated.
It's not as dry.
Desiccated is Mars but it's probably it's the driest place on earth.
It's so we can get some of the same effects and if we are looking for life and
desiccated dry places,
well this is a good place to test the same techniques at least at a first cut.
Uh,
we would make field use of astrobiology sort of prototypes of fight instruments
and at the same time grabbed samples that we can take back to our lab.
So we can compare the performance of the flight instrument versus the tabletop.
Expensive well calibrated,
well tuned instrument that can get two orders of magnitude more precision
probably then what we can put onto a rover.
We would have to,
since you light speed means that on Mars that plus the deep space network only
gives you two windows a day to talk to your missions.
You know that plus the 10 minutes in each direction means that whatever you send
out there has to be autonomous.
It had not only has to be self driving,
it has to be self drilling,
it has to be self transporting in terms of samples and the instruments.
All have to be able to not burn themselves up.
And so there's the autonomy and the software implications of this are
significant.
I mean just the drilling alone is something that on earth still is pretty much a
human dominated activity.
Even deep sea drilling,
the oil and gas industry that's done remotely as done joystick with people in
Houston or similar places doing VR work.
But do you have human operators just as if they were flying drones,
they're essentially flying the drill while on the bottom of the sea floor.
It's still a human governed,
that kind of reaction time.
And finally we have to know if anything we're discovering is valid.
So we have to have a control.
So the best field science and also to study the desert and the outcome as a Mars
analog in and of itself.
And I'll skim through some of this I guess,
but this is just to put it into context,
how we were addressing science was in terms of figuring out what are the limits
of life in an extreme environment and Dewey find biomarkers there on the
surface.
More about that later.
And is this a good Martian low to mid latitude model?
The technology since there's the software automation and autonomy,
surface mobility and drilling,
integrating those together.
Yes,
curiosity has a drill but it has a five centimeter drill about the size of my
thumb designed for sampling outcrops and it doesn't get used that it's quite an
engineering challenge as it is.
And then science operations,
how do we do remote surface operations that involve this much complexity
transfer in analysis given the lightspeed and the bandwidth limitations that we
only get to talk to these two the vehicle twice a day.
So we were not saying,
well we address all of these things.
We have a nice AFL looking proposal and a,
the folks within NASA headquarters who look at these things said yea verily go
forth
because they're operating off of a astrobiology roadmap,
which has been revised I guess a couple,
two or three years before that and just would not to be labor.
Since most of you are probably familiar with,
uh,
the main,
where do we come from?
Are we alone?
Although that's as much of a silly question,
but you know,
how can we detect whether that's microbial are complex?
And then what does that tell us about our own future?
We strive to investigate a bunch of different science goals,
but the ones that are most relevant here are how would early life interact and
evolve with the changing environment because the environment in the Atacama and
show a changed dramatically over the past few million years.
And when it's been gone to a very dry desiccated,
in some respects,
it may be a good model for what could have happened billions of years ago on
Mars.
If we look at early Mars versus going up to the present,
it also gives us an idea of how to look for habitable environments and how to
recognize signatures of life by looking at do we find signatures of life in this
very barren,
hostile environment.
So astrobiology is a motivation,
but at the same time we have to find a place.
There are no perfect earth analogs.
Everything is a partial cause.
We're not on Mars,
we're not on your rope or we're not really,
everything is uh,
we may be very dry and desiccated in Chile,
but we're hot.
We're not cold in the ambient pressure is way too high.
I can go to the dry valleys in Antarctica.
We've tested there with past drills and instruments and it's pretty dry,
although not as dry as the outcome.
And it's cold.
But again,
the ambient temperature and pressure and it's a little bit wetter.
I can likewise go to the Arctic to the big impact crater.
And the soil has been broken up.
You have something very akin to regolith from the meteor impact,
but it's a bit wetter and it's not as dry.
So you,
you'll take your pick,
you can sort of have some venn diagram of a possible characteristics that look
like Mars or other places,
but you can't have all of it.
So we decided to take this to Chile.
We looked at three sites,
one near Epica,
one at Maria Elena south,
which is the listed as number three there on that chart and one at the young guy
station,
ghost town about 90 kilometers east southeast of Antofagasta
and pictures of these,
there are gypsum polygons.
There are eroded formations.
There's a,
there are solars with the haylight deposits and salt crystals that actually hook
up as though they were arms coming out Zombie like out of the ground.
We ended up sticking with number two at Antofagasta both because it has a
variety of things.
It's drier than anywhere except for maybe number three at Maria Elena south and
it has a derelict,
uh,
sort of ghost town abandoned agricultural station,
which we can outfit to support us for as far as the logistics go.
But uh,
this is a very barren place.
One of my cohorts,
one of the folks working on this on the field science side,
Mary Beth Wilhelm is about to publish a paper talking about a transect going
from further south to the north from warmer and cooler and wetter to hotter and
drier.
And this is what she's finding.
These are actually early a results from this past field season.
A little map at the bottom tells you roughly the geographical,
although that's a,
again,
read instead of a left or right,
that's really kind of south to north,
but it shows that as you go from extreme,
merely extremely arid,
too hyper arid,
the markers like psycho appropriate in the second a chart down,
go to zero,
the LDS ship,
total fluorescence,
that's solid.
That is again,
from this year's uh,
testing,
we saw that samples fed two solid.
By the time we get to young guy,
we have something like eight out of 256 that we were still seeing any positive
hits on.
Same thing.
Fatty acids fall down.
Basically the,
they're the,
the signs of life or activity diminished to almost nothing by the time we reach
young gay or Maria Elena south,
which is even further over here.
So in that sense,
it's probably a really good analog site.
And again,
it's a good simulant for what we might find at Mars.
Again,
it's to the pressure's too hot and it's too warm,
but it's very dry,
very desiccated.
And,
uh,
we're not seeing signs of ongoing activity.
And again,
from Mary Beth's work,
this is a impress currently.
We see it changes as you go from the south to the north.
And this is,
you know,
looking at this transition zone from biologically active where we see at least a
few occasional Intelysis things growing and rocks or a fuel plants are lichens a
little bit of biomass to places like young gay or Maria Elena where there's no
visible activity,
low biomass and the,
when we say significant racism,
[inaudible] amino acids,
what that indicates is they're decaying.
Typically they have been irradiated and they're breaking down it's dead stuff,
Jim.
Basically it's very dead stuff.
Most of what we were finding was on the order of 10 to 40,000 years dead stuff.
It just in the surface soil.
So there's not much activity and most of what you find are microbial skeletons,
whom that may have even blown in some distances from other places.
So that was sort of framing why we went to this particular bear in place and
what collection of stuff we wanted to take with us.
And why.
So a little bit about,
well what did we actually go out and do or what are we in the middle of doing?
The first year we went out did some of these studies that you just saw displayed
here.
Oh and a sampled at young gay as well as some of the other sites,
Maria Elena and the Epica site.
We took two instruments,
the wet chemistry lab and solid,
you saw some solid results on that previous chart.
Wet Chemistry lab,
brass board,
even though it flew on Phoenix.
What we have is a had been in storage for about six or seven years and was a
brass board,
not a full flight unit.
So we had to renovate that.
We started work on the two instruments we didn't have in hand and we got a new
drill and a new robot arm since the ones that we had originally proposed broke.
And that's part of the downside of taking things out and trying to break them.
And sometimes you succeed and it's not necessarily a bad thing,
but a,
you want to break things because if you don't break things,
you're not learning and you're not able to improve and go and come up with
things that won't break later.
But still you have to keep putting things together then.
And I keep having to justify the budgets.
So this year and February,
2017,
our objective was to take the k rex to rover,
which is,
um,
a vehicle from Terry Fong is here in the audience.
It is his group that has developed this as one of their stable of rovers over
the years.
So in collaboration with that,
we have a honeybee and NASA drill that you see,
uh,
up to the upper right kind of sticking up,
kind of a gold spindle with a long shaft protruding and um,
MDA aerospace,
sort of a Canadian contribution I suppose,
although it's are u s Uhso subsidiary,
um,
arm with a scoop on the end of that.
And they did the Phoenix and insight arms and uh,
helped JPL with the curiosity arms.
So they have a long track record.
A Honeybee did the rock abrasion tool for grinding things away from the Mer
rovers and the dust removal tool on curiosity.
These are all entities with some direct experience in flight hardware.
So this is,
it's sitting in the Atacama as it was after nightmares of getting it through
Chilean custom's included in this rover.
We have three different robotic subsystems there.
This is the k rex to rover and its own autonomous navigation.
And you see it there even though maybe the perspective isn't as good,
but the tracks left by the rover as it trembled up a hill.
That's about a 1520 degree angle.
Although again,
since you're looking uphill,
it's not quite as obvious.
But the rover is going and finding its own way around the boulders and obstacles
in his path.
We have the arm that again from MDA aerospace and it was something that we're
not usually always scratching our head and we look at it.
But uh,
and then we have the latest generation of honeybee robotics,
rotary percussive,
lightweight,
15 kilos,
two meter class drills.
Usually the deal there is that honeybee designs the mechanics and we usually
write their software over at NASA ames,
so we do the drill control.
They do the drill mechanisms.
Usually we don't fight each other too much.
The rover itself will carry four instruments,
maybe a fifth,
maybe three.
We will see this will develop,
the arm will deploy sample two individual instruments,
one after another after another.
We're just taking a scoop and basically dumping dirt and three different
physical locations and it can autonomously navigate and uh,
possibly even we'll be able to identify if we get a little bit of supplemental
support,
good locations to drill on its own.
That would be a coup.
If we can get that in a couple of years.
Rover navigation,
this is just a showing one of the Atacama from this past season,
I believe it might've been the same run.
You saw it trending uphill just at the rover.
Both does image processing for navigation and has a lidar mounted on it as well.
You know,
we have to be careful with the lidar.
We take it to other countries because it's a export controlled.
But nonetheless,
it can autonomously find obstacles,
navigates to identify and do a limited amount of contextual analysis that we
might be able to leverage in future years.
The robot arm replaced our old robot arm,
which eventually we killed.
Um,
given this is a sort of a track family history from the insight in Phoenix arms.
We just got this,
we have been tuning it ever since.
And uh,
our,
the software for controlling it of course as the biggest problem because the,
you know,
we didn't want the flight code because we want to operate it on a laptop or on
an embedded thing off the rover.
So they had to write something new for us specifically.
And we're still working with that,
but it is not killed anyone yet.
There was once upon a time,
a,
uh,
an apocryphal story of a,
somebody working violating buddy principle rules around a robot arm in a lab
late at night on a Friday,
who then had forgotten to set the safety perimeter app if the system got
activated,
came around and scratched them,
at which point they ran down the hallway shouting,
I need medical help.
I've been attacked by a robot
that's only somewhat anecdotal,
but I'll leave it at that.
The new drill,
which is the fifth generation of lightweight planetary prototype drills that we
have broken in succession was funded by a combination of projects.
Two of them are ones I'm working on air ads and a another one that we'll be
going to Spain in two months and the resource prospector project,
which is currently in sort of a pre phase a state at Nasa Ames and elsewhere.
It's a joint 15 kilo,
two meter capable of the,
most of the time we only operate it with a single drill strings,
so that's about little over one meter and it is able to operate into about plus
70 see down to a lunar equivalent minus 230 sea temperatures.
So it's a ruggedized and designed to be able to be cold world are sort of Europa
compatible in that sense or lunar compatible for resource prospector.
So we took this out,
we bundled this together,
we drove,
we integrated,
we drove it,
we braved the dust devils and customs and shipping and all the other constraints
that sometimes get in the way of doing some sort of a technical test out in the
middle of nowhere and were successful in getting not quite 14 meters,
but uh,
that was doing actually darn good considering deepest was full stroke,
two meters.
And we saw three of the five major fault modes simply occur in the course of a
mother nature binding or over torque.
You know,
basically if we have something that we are going into and it grabs the side of
the Auger,
in this case corkscrewing which typically comes when you try to retract,
if it catches on an edge,
suddenly your intention,
it's like you're trying to pull the cork out of the bottle,
you're trying to unscrew it and it's not unscrewing the way you would like it or
hard material,
which can also be a worn out drillbit or something else that is causing your
rate of penetration to go to zero.
So we found some nice ways,
way in which we can fault or break the drill while it's on the rover so he can
then look at how does being on a suspension or my new movements in the rover
platform effect compared to a lander platform or something that's more stable.
So those were all very useful for us.
We also managed to demonstrate that we could take the dirt,
the sample that was coming up out of the ground and transfer it.
Since we don't have the instruments on it this past year,
we could still send it to a catchment bucket or a sample jar on the back.
In one case,
we did put an instrument back there just so we could say we had done it,
but that wasn't a really an integration
but still successful.
We should also,
as you see here and on the opening charge,
in order to when we were testing,
we have to clean very thoroughly when about four successive levels of solvent
between a test between sampling.
So,
and we don't want to breathe on it or bring our own microbes.
So we have to wear bunny suits,
masks,
hair nets,
booties,
which and when it's already a hundred degrees and you're in the sun and you're
in a bunny suit,
sweating,
bending over and trying to swabs small amounts of,
you know,
either alcohol or something stronger solvent wise,
that's tough work but it was necessary every single 10 centimeter sample.
So when we did clean samples it we,
it was time consuming and you see them in the middle here of a cleaning cycle
and someone back off about 20 or 30 meters who's recording the data from the
previous sample set
for anyone who is into penetration rates and the hardware involved for the
drill.
This is a comparison of the new drill versus the old drill.
The biggest thing here is really the stroke length is improved and the masses a
little bit higher from 13 to 15 kilos,
but we have a lot more torque that we can play with,
which keeps us from getting stuck.
The old Lita drill would notoriously wimpy and some materials if you went into
basalt or if he went into solid ice.
I once had to dig one out in the Arctic with the leader drill and air ads should
not have this issue.
Good thing if we're planning on,
if we're looking for ice deposits for the resource prospector folks,
we don't want this getting stuck in ice.
And again,
honeybee does the hardware.
NASA ames typically does the software.
We leverage our m slice sequencer and uh,
take some diagnostic modules that we uh,
we reasoned about the g we have some ordinary limit checky expert system.
He stuff we look at vibrations and do some um,
genetic algorithms to basically do the frequency shifts and process the
frequency shifts in realtime.
And then we do a little bit of model comparison to see if it's behaving the way
we think it should be behaving.
We have to arbitrary traits all of these down at the bottom where it says
diagnostics and then decide with the exec that we are,
uh,
you,
what recovery action if anything or what parameters to shift in realtime.
And we have to handshake.
We're,
we keep flipping back and forth.
I think we were originally going to use zero Mq.
I think we were just you back to DDS now in terms of how we handshake and what
we do with honeybee.
One other aspect of handing material,
assuming we're successful in our automated drilling and the rover has positioned
us and we have something in the scoop while we have dirt.
Okay.
We have pulverized rock.
Well,
so what?
Uh,
but instruments have to be automated too.
If I have an instrument that's designed to only operate on finely milled flowery
particles and they're going to extract and I dump a bunch of gravel in it,
then I've just killed my instrument mission over or at least that instruments
over.
So this led to lots of gnashing of teeth and a discovery proposal I was working
on in the 2013 to 2015 timeframe that called icebreaker where we had huge fights
among the team working on the proposal back and forth across institutions
screaming and yelling and you know,
project managers being replaced all over this one issue of can we take the risk
of screening or not screening sample particles being fed to it from a drill like
this.
And because we had an instrument that couldn't handle anything bigger than about
two millimeters diameter or it could handle maybe one or two two millimeter are
bigger particles,
but nothing bigger than that.
And so did we need to build a saas spa like on Msl,
a complex filters,
screening 12 motors,
lots of degrees of freedom or it could we just have a simple screen or not
screen anything and just say,
well,
we might get a bigger rock,
but we probably will happen so infrequently,
we're not going to worry about it.
You know,
I was in the latter camp.
Other people were in the former camp since they're not here to defend
themselves,
I won't revisit that argument.
Only to say this show that this is an important thing that a will the next time
we propose this in a year or two will undoubtedly be used as ammunition by both
sides.
So if you look at this,
you can see that the distribution is mostly in the OE half millimeter quarter
millimeter and the 500 or 250 uh,
micro meter range.
If you look at the proportions of the bulk here,
and if you go all the way out to the 2000 which would be two millimeters is a
little tiny bit to 3% 1% 4% and the s the 60 2020 and greater,
130 those are depths brought up from as far as drilling goes on average.
So the stuff that we would really kill about the stuff that might cause hiccups
are the four centimeter,
four millimeter sized particles.
And one of those we have none.
And the others,
we have just a tiny amount,
1% of the sample.
So if we're only doing 10 samples,
let's say on a given mission with a given instrument,
1% might show up with a rock.
Okay,
so maybe in one or two of those 10 we might get a rock.
We could probably keep operating with that.
So this is a useful result when we're making those sort of risk assessments are
will we jam up our internals of our instruments?
Have you think back to the description of the astrobiology field laboratory,
one of the things it was concerned about was contamination,
not just how do you sterilize it,
how do you make it very clean when you bring it?
And that's sort of comparable to the people you saw on the bunny suits,
making it clean in that sense,
but also the,
how do you know you're not just observing the life you brought with you suppose
you are contaminating your own mechanism for detecting life.
So we needed to,
we have needed to study this and get some sort of a handle on it.
So we have done some tracer studies.
This shows one from this past February where we essentially took
hydrogen bromide as spray.
And laid it across the area.
We're going to drill into,
then drilled through with a clean sterilized drill after we had backed away from
it.
And uh,
see what concentration of the bromine shows up in the samples coming down from
the surface.
Okay.
Then the one in the center,
we actually sprayed the tracer on the drill bit itself in a different whole
before it went down below the surface.
So one of the things this tells you,
we also tried to control for how often,
is there percussion,
the little hammer signs or do we see any moisture in the whole,
the little droplets [inaudible]
as you might expect if you're just drilling one hole,
as you drill,
a pile of cuttings builds up.
Those of you who've used a hand tool,
you know if you do home improvement or something else,
you drill into something.
A little pile comes up the auger and builds deposits itself near the borehole to
surface.
And then once you've drilled enough and enough stuff has come up,
some of that material starts falling back down in the hole again as you shake it
or bump it around.
So here you see that,
um,
as you went deeper you started seeing more and more of the tracer and you might
say,
well that's counterintuitive.
The tracer was on the surface.
Why are you,
you know,
you're going deeper and further away.
Why are you seeing more in the samples you're bringing up?
Well answer is is that you weren't seeing material you had brought with you,
you are seeing circulation,
you are bringing up particles,
dumping them on the surface.
As you drill deeper,
which then fell down again back down in the hole and sometimes made a couple of
cycles of this and each time they would carry more of tracer back down the hole.
So something at the surface in proximity could actually be more of a problem to
some extent.
Now I suppose if you went really,
really deep,
if this is a hundred meter drill,
I imagine this would taper off at some point as far as the effects go,
but down to a meter,
this is what we saw when you sprayed it on the drill bit.
That's more or less straight across.
You might've seen a little bit of tapering off just as you are finally wearing.
Of course levels are higher than just what was coming down from the surface.
And then finally when you would drill a little,
bring it back up,
drill a little bit more and bring it back up.
You are sort of both exciting material on the surface and exposing the bit to it
as you went in and out of it.
So it was a bit higher than the first case but not as high as the second case.
And again,
there may have been some attenuation going on as you bring it up and out,
you knock the pile back so less of it was falling down after awhile.
So again,
cross contamination.
We don't want to introduce our own microbes into our instruments,
so we have to get an idea of how do we drill cleanly and is this going to be a
problem with our own contamination.
And it looks like it is
a little bit about our instruments.
Um,
and I'll wrap this up with the wet chemistry lab.
10 kilos flew on Phoenix A,
we've taken it out there already.
It detected perchlorate on Mars in 2007 so it can give us the habitability in
the background of what we're looking for.
The signs of life detector,
I talked a little bit about this.
It's an amino assay.
It can look for a grid of potential molecules or markers of past life and uh,
can operate in the presence of perchlorate.
It doesn't heat anything up and it's an antibody match
and some examples.
So if you notice as you go down,
you may see antibodies matching differently.
This is from some 2016 data from a pit to near where you saw the picture of the
rover before.
Notice the,
you got way more signatures when you got to 80 centimeters depth in this case,
big signature there and then suddenly you go to 20 centimeters back to almost
background levels again.
And at 130 there's hardly anything.
You also,
if you notice at the surface in that particular pitch or in that particular
hold,
it was hardly anything but desiccated upper surface in a much of what you're
seeing at 80 or 100 at a meter down,
maybe a couple of million years old fossilized material
from this year's data.
You could see that after this 256 or 51,
um,
potential hits,
you only saw about eight proteins as far as him,
the solid or in this case LD chip.
If you take it out of the solid case and you're doing it in the lab.
And here's a comparison of young gays results with those of some of the other
sites.
This is also for Mary Beth's paper,
the Mila microfluidic flute life analyzer,
Eh,
you can see a picture of the chemical laptop in the upper left corner and it
can,
it does a excellent job of amino acid analysis potentially,
at least for a portable unit.
It looks a little bit like in practice,
like a mister coffee sitting on top of the laptop.
So that's an inglorious way to refer to it,
I suppose.
But we did have it up and running in the field.
As we see here,
there's the extractor there.
Start Real.
That's really not a mister coffee.
It does have a funnel on the top,
but that's way more,
you know,
no coffee grains in that at all.
But then you see the chemical laptop in the back.
So the two were operated separately and off to the side with samples that we,
Jace basically just carried it from the rover over to the field to give to the
meal of folks and they did their analysis.
Next year we will have the laser disruption mass spec.
Again,
it's half of the Exomars Moma instrument.
Of course as Xo Morris has continued to slide,
when we propose this in 2014 it was going to be a 2016 flights.
So we were going to have this already tested,
already flown and instrument that we are simply going to leverage.
Now it's slipped to 2020 and may go to 2022 who knows what's means though that
they are,
you know,
we're now still working with the engineering unit and as they look at their own
design and redesign cycle,
so they have a harder time getting hardware ready for us.
So their schedule has slipped.
They didn't make it in time for the February field test.
We are,
look,
they also have to operate in a vacuum chamber.
So we have to create a Mars atmosphere inside of the cylinder that we are
pumping down trundling along on the back of the rover in the Atacama.
So in some sense we have a sort of Mars like environment here and we're
recreating the atmospheric constituents for this instrument as we go along.
Yeah,
something we had never really anticipated,
but we had been playing around with the [inaudible] nanopore sequencing,
which you can get for about a thousand bucks from a company in England,
Oxford Research,
I think.
And there's a picture of one held the next to a haylight nodule it over in one
of the solars.
You can see it's literally,
it's the closest thing so far to a tricorder in the sense of being able to
identify and sequence something and identify organisms and do censuses.
What's,
you know,
what microbes are here and here is a one that we weren't expecting to see Selena
bacteria.
You see the little thin blue wedge at the Young Gay Clr in 2016 but it's
comparable to the PCR and centrifuge,
you know,
traditional DNA sequencing approaches.
But you can do it in your hand from a laptop as long as you can keep it cold
and some more men I and analysis and data from this past year showing both the
archaea bacteria if we're looking at for extreme of files,
even viruses and then the haylight liking versus non haylight liking splits and
the archaea and bacteria respectively.
Okay.
We've also taken our field science samples.
Ben Done offline analysis both to young gay and study the region better and to
also provide a control for what we're doing with the instruments.
And one of the things that Jocelyn do,
regear row,
what are the team members from Johns Hopkins found is that she had taken samples
in the area in 2013 in 2015 there was a rainfall event,
very,
very rare there.
And just,
and she noticed a significant shift in the populations,
uh,
bacteria.
We're a much more diverse compared to the archaea or you know,
the extreme of files and they are out competing the Saltin strategist as it were
then.
So cyanobacteria,
which you hardly ever see in that area were suddenly popped up to in the
noticeable numbers.
So this was an interesting sort of shift in terms of uh,
climate change effects even in the Atacama in these haylight populations of
microbes just as a side effect of doing this for the sake of the project.
Otherwise.
And this compares traditional methods to the results with the men I n so fairly
comparable and uh,
we'll probably go forward with that.
So things which are wrap up that we are currently doing,
we finished our field deployment,
we had a,
we will head our initial Ameela test.
We have the laser disruption mass spec going to a vacuum chamber in June.
In the autumn,
we will be taking these instruments and instrument mockups and putting them on
Terry's rover there along with the drill in the arm and seeing if they will all
fit and if we drive them around and bang them around and get them all dusty,
will they still work or will they fry themselves?
We'd rather find out if they fry themselves here in mountain view before rather
than taking them to the Atacama and we'll continue to do sample analysis and do
our vibration,
thermal and power of environments characterization.
So that'll take us to maybe next February or March two year three.
So the three of the multiple steps we have done,
two of them,
the first two 2018 we'll put the instruments on the rover that will be locally
controlled except the LDM s will probably be operated on the side still given
their lagging now and then in leading the 2019 early 2019 we will operate this
as a mission sim to at least some level sending it commands remotely from a Nasa
Ames or other places.
And that concludes what I had prepared for y'all.
It's,
so we've got about 10 minutes I guess for questions if anybody's interested.
Thanks.
Yeah,
we're all looking at it.
Okay.
So the bottom of the hole on the bottom of the hole
[inaudible]
this is a 2.5 meter deep pit that has been documented in the literature,
actually has been a in multiple papers.
It a is over about 10 kilometers west of the young gay station,
sorta the ghost town area,
but is one of the primary research areas and where the samples that are labeled
as young gay come from the vicinity of this because we actually,
without using a drill or other means,
this was dug out with people in bunny suits with pick axes.
So if you can imagine being carefully bundled up to avoid contaminating what's
down at two meters down because if you've got tiny traces of organic material
and biomarkers,
you know you don't want to spit on it or sweat on it.
So you have to be bundled up and you're in a hundred degree heat and you're
digging at something in your,
you know,
below the level of this.
So you can imagine how much of a adventure that has been by five or 10 years
worth of successive graduate students doing their PhD dissertations coming to
this location among others.
Also,
it makes a nice looking up at the field science crew photo,
which is,
I just thought they looked inquisitive,
so like to use it.
So
in the back,
my question is about the rover.
Is that the final look and feel of the rover that's going to Mars because they
noticed some differences like this is four wheel versus like usually literally
six wheel.
And is there anything that you guys learned from the current issues with the
wheels like damage your wheels and the aluminum wheels?
Well,
there are mobility architecture issues.
Yeah,
of course.
The irony of course is you're sitting next to the rover guy as it were,
uh,
and the audience.
So this is really his rover,
but there are not everyone is wedded to the rocker bogey architecture that you
see on the Mer rovers or curiosity.
It's one amongst several.
There are advantages in terms of maneuverability and getting yourself in and out
of things between just a rocker architecture independently like you see here.
We did have to the look at if you notice we had rubber tires and um,
while that probably wouldn't go to planetary surface because rubber has organic,
you leave as you,
anyone who walks along a highway,
you see bits of rubber that are shed by tire.
So you're thinking,
well aren't you going to contaminate your samples with bits of rubber?
So we actually needed to do drive the rover over ground before we drilled it and
then take the drilled spent samples and sample in surface samples and send them
off for analysis to see if we were getting appreciable contamination.
Not from bro mine but from tire rubber and we've had to look at that and things
like outgassing of solvents and things wells.
In terms of the Longterm rover,
it probably really is a function as much of the intended,
the surface roughness and sort of the masses,
you know,
the sandy versus from obstacle size dimensions of the obstacle.
You know there are architectures where you might be better off with treads
depending on the treads are pretty heavy.
So I would not say that the,
the dual rocker architecture is inherently superior for Mars or Europa.
It's really a trade off or a trade study according to your design intended
environment
over on the side blue shirt.
Um,
you mentioned earlier on that one goal is to have the rover be able to determine
what is a good place to drill.
So my question is what constitutes a good place to trail and how would the rover
go about determining that?
Okay,
what is a good place to drill?
The way a geologist or an investigator in the field would choose this?
If I were working for an exploration company,
I would want to do seismic or other geophysical surveys and have some idea of
the strata and what lies underneath my feet for underneath my wheels.
Figuratively speaking,
problem is on most planetary surfaces.
We're not going to have that.
We might have something at tens of meters scale that we've gotten from ground
penetrating radar for some sort of remote sensing,
but we're not going to know down to the meter scale probably of what's down
there.
So how do we know that there's this interesting feature two meters down here,
but it's not over there.
So we can only go by visuals and surface and we can look for patterns,
things that look like outflows,
things that look like a fractal structures in the soil or on rock surfaces.
We can also do the logistical or practical side of obstacle avoidance.
We didn't hit,
let's not drill or position ourselves over a boulder or over something with a
sharply canted,
um,
surface that is going to deflect our drill and make it just operationally
difficult to go through.
So if we can handle the,
at least the,
let's at least find a nice flat space to drill as opposed to the top of a
boulder that's at least doing sort of our bottom level of Maslow's hierarchy,
well,
at least not doing any harm.
And then if we can work it up and start picking things that are more visually
more interesting,
we can start weeding out all the bulk of the things that are less interesting.
And even if I can throw away 85% of the potential drill sites,
including the tops of boulders,
that means I've just narrowed it down to 10 or 15% of interesting spaces.
And while those still may be boring in the end,
I'm still a lot better off if I can do that,
especially if I have to lift the rover,
make that decision because of the communications lag and the bandwidth issues.
And we are talking about,
you know,
what's,
how would you incorporate remote sensing data?
I,
there are folks that,
uh,
colleagues who are working on that now,
how do you incorporate visual from a rover or from something and whatever remote
sensing you've got to try to figure out where to prospect or where to drill,
you know,
where it is.
X marks the proverbial spot.
Any other questions?
Well,
and that case,
thank you very much for your attention and for inviting me over.
And,
uh,
if you,
if anyone is interested,
I have a few of our most recent mission deployment patches here for your taking
as you like to go along.
And uh,
feel free to grab one.
Thanks again.